welcome to this video playing never end
never end to forget it how they more
than always okay so after some move all
the wrinkles we probably get over oxy
always welcome to dwell in those after
there should be six f4 is a good move I
have not yet really studied this all
that well but it is it is so is it would
move let's see what is he doing here I
can from the Queen d2 where I have five
ideas in those positions is it good here
already
probably not f5 takes takes Bishop takes
be foil that's an idea I just got Queen
five even you know anyway I don't don't
need to look at this that chief for is
an idea for him I'm not so we used to
play this with F form what is he trying
to do right before maybe
[Music]
detectors work really f-five takes takes
bishop takes before and 25 really it
might work I mean it looks terrible
but it might work might give 5 yeah I'm
playing it I mean maybe it doesn't work
but it's the way to to handle this I
guess he just has this move and now 95
probably I can take c2 here
unfortunately now okay let's play this
for first okay it's not the end of the
world if he does probably okay we'll see
what am i threatening okay it doesn't
matter anymore because he has taken so
now I can course I can we capture that I
need to also cook to check if I have
something else probably not so take and
now probably 94 is the is this way to
defend it's a series of only moves but
no this one and 94 doesn't it doesn't
feel great neither form yeah I don't
know maybe I have some compensation but
it's not not all that clear really I
think you should take it to you should
allowing Bishop d3 looks a bit strange
and I preserve this bishop against this
king
not sure maybe Knight f5 is actually a
good move okay
I would like to play Bishop give for now
and trade his Bishop and like then I
have got 93 and so nice Kings that is
weakened not easy to handle for black
now Fisher deep voice isn't annoying
move
what's the Bishop f4 just take is six
would also be very good for white yeah
this one okay here probably better
deform where is he going so cam shaking
or I also have Queen g5 but then equals
back listen too much
okay now 93 looks very logical one night
f1 okay let's do this okay that looks
good each five Queen age form and I have
a really really nice attacking position
and if he moves the King I have six
maybe Queen g5 actually taking here and
the text still attacking c-form I wanted
to go look everyone but then you can
take on C form it's not probably I
didn't played the best possible way M
hmm
not good
Knight takes is also an idea no this
okay
time warning
can you take a turn
probably not
96 I can take I can also take a 796 54
and I have nothing really my time my
time management is so bad but look at
7:00 next check Luke f8 check check
black resigns yeah I no idea what's
going on yeah I mean well I rehab no
idea I have no idea so let's let's have
a look there I mean I really was unsure
how to play I know that f4 is a good
move but I'm not very knowledgeable
there immediately before wins of course
well yeah just I mean I kind of knew
that this shouldn't work but i FF 5
actually does win I just didn't
understand it
so b5 is the window here ok now it
shouldn't it really shouldn't work I
because at the end at 5 hangs yeah I was
just thinking ok my knight hangs but in
this situation there's still a double
attack going on and I win appease him
with a good very good position it's got
thorns good so that that would have
ended the game already
and here this is this is not it is not
convincing our queen III is an
interesting one
check yeah that would have ended my
attack him okay okay yeah night at high
horse betrayer I suspected that you have
to play g3 and this is not what I want
gather the opportunity was earlier
now the the situation is very important
and okay the rooks III wins but you have
so many promising looking moves very
difficult to find the best 194 now makes
much more sense than what I did hook f6
is just a clumsy move Queen f3 and here
taking only six was indeed right I
didn't want to trade twins here this is
this is all now like I'm playing on
instinct with 20 seconds h5 and leg wins
that's not an easy move to make your
queen h6 is made okay okay so that
doesn't win check and now I'm winning
again now K let the corruption a over 10
seconds just a matter of nerves and also
yeah put up a metaphor for luckier with
what you see what you don't see little
bit okay thanks